321 vai ver cabeça de vespas lançou a 1h
olá sou bom eu também consiga incluir a
bola em 321 mais barato num jogo que
quem fala é o dark sejam muito bem
vindos a mais um mundial e mostrar de
que mais um vídeo do microscópio mas
antes disto a explicar porque botou uma
bola de futebol
não é a bola que interessa mas sim uma
aplicação não só está bem mas nenhuma
proteção chamada o futebol é uma
aplicação sobretudo bom tem no time
jogadores os resultados dos jogos onde
está a ajudar a equipa quando a equipa
joga em casa onde todas as noites de
muito futebol que está além da aplicação
e ela estava andréia iphone é bom o
iphone todo fomos nós conseguirmos
encontrar vamos tratar o pessoal vai ter
briga aqui minha aplicação imaginei que
a minha equipa favorita é o real madrid
como podem ver só que já tem as
condições da sua equipa e as principais
conclusões do estudo sobre o real madrid
agora só quero que iniciar segue uma
competição aqui vocês podem ser as
condições que estão a abrir agora você
corta se não contratar cristiano ronaldo
em que é porque ela é a aplicação mais
completa e como está o movimento é bom e
claro que é grave e portanto podem
baixar a vontade eu vou tentar
recomendar a aplicação das fotos na bola
2 um pai e sua irmã sou muito de vocês
pediram a segunda parte de outros 27 com
microscópio e eu sei eu sei que vocês
querem que eu espero é que vocês querem
ver o sangue e saiu sair mas ele tem
sido muito difícil arranjar mesmo já fui
a todas as quintas equipe ninguém
consegue cruzar as pernas acabou eu
prometo que vou conseguir voltar o mais
rápido possível até então você não
consigo portanto aguardem com a 0 mas o
cinto vai ser observado concertos parte
2 com um microscópio vocês nem sabem que
opinião virgin é muito incerto nojento e
bonita mesmo tempo só vai instalar o
primeiro aí ou ainda em grande e tão
logo a deus está bem fico nem porque
apanha alguns dias vamos ver que é muito
incerta o pessoal
e vamos tentar atingir os 6 e os lights
neste vídeo não sei se é assim tomou
gente mas eu encontrei um parceiro morto
de fora e elas fazem que estavam de
licença microscópio ou ser muito cruel
o elenco passa já está morto mas quando
eu quero que vocês acham isso querem ver
isso mesmo ela sofre milagres com você
em bora bora lá então só havia o nosso
primeiro evento vai ser roubado e 32 e
já tomei qualquer coisa já previra a
deus tá muito depois avistado do barril
o que não quer passa não só tem uma pata
o ontem muitos picos nunca pensei que
você se partido valeu nilvan sobre
menores no total é muito lindo eu vou
tentar a sorte na primeira o botafogo
mas não sou muito da primeiro gol ele
olha eu olho para os pés mas já lançou
oito louvo a deus meu pai gigante que dá
pra ver tudo na barriga eu acho
importante apesar de eu já estar vencer
que eu acho que eu tenho que coisas
interessantes do que aquilo que nunca
nunca é que é um curso louvável sério
parece uma minhoca é esta a lâmina deu e
estou mesmo só essa lâmina que corta o
que eu acho que sabe isto só para saber
um pouco asa tem muito lixo nada deu
muito isso aqui é só aqui onde as asas
nascem e nesta parte de cima no tal
muito bonito e não só ao próximo inseto
então vai ser um efeito que salta muito
no pleno e do campo vamos ver um
detalhou também que os copos vocês
conseguem mesmo eo placar do jogo foi
muito porque eu tenho uma pátria gigante
estatal contato muito alto e agora nós
vamos ver se ela é bonita não é não
saber 4 3 2 1 + gafanhoto
olha aí já começamos a ver qualquer
coisa que tem na língua dentro do
microscópio e ficou evento ea cabeça só
de olho que têm artilharia do espanhol
microscopista falar um pouco da primeira
liga abc dão perfeitamente meu tá muito
bom o caiaque já começamos a ver as
patas meu esta perna sua vez só é a
diferença do músico é para não faltar
muito alta que é pato por trás olha olha
a quantidade de pêlos meu eu acho que é
um pix mesmo bem duro a bandeira é
amarela e verde está podre por dentro do
futebol afirmou ter um animal muito
quando é que eu só falta eu andei
rua eu faço três coisas ao mesmo tempo
eu vou tentar aqui ver as asas dele eu
acho que estou aqui mas agora achava
conseguiu o saque e um ataque masi bem
em frente meu é fazer bem distintos a
dispararem está repartida com textura do
réptil diploma gato assim é muito
persigo brutal a pessoal vai lá então a
próxima inseto que vai ser o mais o daee
nesta vida é seguir a música clássica
música com mais rodagem e um cinto
emenda eu somos 33 somos 300 que ninguém
quer no planeta mosquito mel é emoção
nem ninguém quer dizer pois depois temos
com quatro piores em todo mundo que é
vespa uma vez tudo isso não dá não dá
pra confiar não dá não dá e sobra lá 321
vai meu bebês pandas não sou muito linda
vez que não podem ver aqui pata relação
bem forte também tem muito músculo aqui
tem muitos pêlos das patas
ok eu voltei e voltei aqui vou dizer que
só querer fugir dela que o pico o
coração o comportamento não sei se sabe
mas quando uma vez que o pico em alguém
automaticamente morre do coração dela
está é uma função importante é esquecer
pra mim mas não só a textura está muito
linda eu vou tentar conquistar fusão ou
dá pra ver a prever um fusão dela e
assim não conseguir mesmo não
conseguirem isso que elas esperam e esta
foi essa coisa eu aposto que se eu ficar
ali continua sendo nenê nunca dá pra
confiar mesmo morta elas podem ficar ok
agora também de virada mas não só
pessoal é bem diferente também é bem
mais simples até aqui só vou tentar dar
um zoom vezes mil aqui na barriga dela e
vamos ver o que acontece não fez vai
ficar à espera
ficou na primeira os poros toda ela tem
brilho para ampliar foi um desvio também
embora eu acho que já está completamente
focado no meu tem muito pela volta a
disparar em que ele mesmo que passeando
aqui nós vemos barriga dela não sem
saber agora as costas libertad enfrenta
qualquer 31 vai cair estão as costas de
vespa sua textura meu tem um grande
frente da equipa não é fixa amarelos
opção tipo mas a primeira pescoço que dá
pra ver onde é que foi a da hora só meu
por limpo é muito
em armas é bem gorda bem loura em breve
um peugeot preto e tem 1 pelo fulham e
wilson a lombriga tempero é claro ao
center um beijo pra temperar um todo o
empenho na bíblia descobrir já descobriu
um segredo do mundo é que tudo tem cunho
o que quer que seja
embora lá pessoal então para o próximo e
um timing certo para fazer 40 incisos à
vista é o quarto e ora inseto do mundo o
se este é o quarto que eu vou mostrar
agora ele quer que eu estou a falar
pessoal do vai do pai desde os velhos do
pai dos veículos no país de todo o
inseto que como melo a captura da onça
um é 011 zangão eu não sei bem o nome
deste inseto mas é muito grande é aquela
velha preta sabe o léo também o eu vou
arriscar por isso na minha mão eu espero
que estejam bem morto significar de eu
morrer vou morrer aqui eu vou ficar eu
vou arriscar por animam as obras não só
o também meu e gigante é preto e preto
pra eu acho que o humor deles o
microscópio eu não sei se agravar quando
eu ficar pode matar mas da picada nem
foto seria e vai lá pessoal vamos ver o
sangue ou a bilhão ou então não vamos
ver preto do oeste vai olhar já vi tudo
preto ele é tão grande que nem cabo no
microscópio lei que o conheceu o poeta o
olho à antena de lá em cima é que o olho
eu vou tentar nadar juventus milan que
no universo que acontece ou dá pra ver
todos os pixels do olho brutal meu tem
muitos pixels no olho
olha a textura do papel tem muitos
buracos na pele muito eu vou estar aqui
e dar um jeito e vamos tentar ver o
corpo e eu acho que vai dar pra mim
muito porque é todo preto e bem
brilhante pela espera
a agesul globo não tem azul quer das 12
mil casos da eu em coisas nada eu tenho
coisas eu tenho surge do nada muita
muita sujidade nada é o que eu tenho
coisas brancas amarradas barrados eu não
sei que temos gente tem muito tranqüilas
não não está vigente ela não é gentil
está muito sujo que dá pra ver os pêlos
demoram aí eu em todo pelo eu tenho
sujidade onde está um sonho que é isso
vou tentar agora vira barriga eu olho aí
outra vez
em teerã e eu acho que já está pessoal e
são paulo já não sei se vocês conseguem
observar em master que bateu é muito
difícil ficar sem resposta até mesmo as
duas ligas também tem muito buraco e
agora vamos tentar achar um função de
lupi que desperta nas pessoas vamos lá
ver se conseguia encontrar agora 3 2 1
mas já está a contar para o rabo deu eu
vou tentar focar agora a cair
isso é o rabo de luta' muito sujo está
muito sujo não conseguir fica num não
assinou nenhum time bateu o vermelho
tendo pelo meio mas não tem muita toa
eu acho que o pkk boca mas não sabes o
que é isto o que está na cabeça eu falei
vocês vocês conseguem ver mostrar o que
é isso eu tenho que uma agulha de gales
entre uma pinça não é mesmo uma pinça é
uma pinça gigantes ou digam que o animal
exatamente o que supostamente explicado
pelo rabo e não pela boca ou então eu
usei essa vivência provocaram nesta
nesta tarde a esposa eu acho que faz
questão que ela fique por dentro ou
então já usou em alguém em 2012 eu vou
tentar prever uma partida eu acho que
não tem já e está previsto pelo estúdio
olhares pelos mil
dá pra ver tudo agora brutal sol portal
mesmo e não só esses foram os nossos 400
podem não gostar e querer vir já sabem
se quiserem ver imagens em suma as
coisas comecem em baixo o boleto e vou
tentar fazer e claro assim que estiveram
esperando acabar eu vou fazer um
tratamento muito rápido mesmo tanto
esperem a guarda em si só para ter um
estado fiquem bem até a próxima
[Música]